[Music]
well tonight after nearly a year and a
half hiatus cirque du soleil's michael
jackson one show welcomes back a live
audience and i got the rare opportunity
to speak with the lead singer about the
time away from the stage and now their
long-awaited return
[Music]
that is the unforgettable voice of south
african singer selawani kayla
after nearly a year and a half away from
the michael jackson one show by cirque
du soleil the cast returns thursday
night we've been waiting for this for 17
months
and time has finally come
the veteran of la nuba and lion king has
always worked
so when the shows went dark she lifted
her light teaching yoga which often
ended in song
i'm just so grateful that i had an
opportunity though just to like
block all that out by going to to the
studio and teach yoga and still like
give back
but now cirque is back and kayla has
been sharing their return on social
media we have new things in the show now
even a gag
are you gonna be like what i know when i
saw you practicing your um your makeup
on instagram i was like whoa
you might also gasp
[Music]
when you watch her character the moon
goddess suspended above the stage
because you're like
lifted all the way up and you have to
come down and people are screaming and
you have to get it you have to be
together you have to like be grounded so
thanks to yoga for that
whether on the ground or in the air the
acrobats dancers and crew are eager and
grateful to bring live entertainment
back to las vegas there's just something
about the energetic
audience and having that from them it
means so much to us
by the way the entire cast kept in touch
every month by connecting on either zoom
or wechat
the first show in front of a live
audience is happening gosh here at seven
o'clock in less than an hour good luck